Single-player games are meant to be played…well,
alone.
That's the point.
But when it comes to horror games, particularly
survival horror, you may want some company
before you dive head-on into an unknown environment.
Even if you're a horror game veteran, we don't
recommend playing any of these games by yourself.
Outlast
A horror game in which a journalist investigates
a freaked-out psychiatric hospital may sound
clichéd, but Outlast is anything but.
The Amnesia-inspired survival horror game
arrived in 2013, marking the first release
by the Canadian indie developer Red Barrels.
Aside from the environment being unnerving,
Outlast's story is intriguing enough to keep
players immersed.
But what really hooks gamers are the mechanics.
There's an indescribable dizzying effect to
the game that somehow makes it all the more
vivid, and the first-person perspective heightens
the entire experience.
We'd wager that more people paused the game
not because they needed to get up and stretch,
but because the game just got too scary.
Outlast is unique among horror games.
As a reporter, you're armed only with a camera,
and unless you're using it as a blunt instrument,
cameras are notoriously sucky weapons.
Even worse, its night vision mode is all you
have to lighten up the hospital.
You don't have a gun, a crowbar, or a kickass
limb-rending chainsaw to defend yourself.
If you see someone charging you, run.
That's your only move.
And given how scary this game is, you'll probably
be running before you realize you triggered
your fight-or-flight response.
Even if you have a few people with you, playing
the game in broad daylight, with the sound
barely loud enough to hear, you still might
not be able to finish.
Resident Evil 4
The most well-known horror franchise is probably
Resident Evil.
That's due, at least in part, to how long
it's been around, as well as the enormously
successful movie franchise it spawned.
In fact, it's the only video game film series
that's ended on its own terms.
While the games have become much more action-oriented
and less about survival horror, they still
have their frightening moments.
The best is undoubtedly Resident Evil 4.
Even if you don't find the game as scary as
other installments, there's no doubt it keeps
you at the edge of your seat.
Resident Evil 4 has plenty of creepy moments
for which you don’t want to be alone — in-game
or otherwise.
The setting creates suspense and terror during
moments where you're not even progressing
through the story.
Have you walked into a place and said to yourself,
"This seems creepy?”
That's exactly what Resident Evil 4 is like,
and that's what makes it terrifying.
Just exploring is scary enough.
Silent Hill 2
It might be one of the greatest stories in
gaming history — and one of the scariest.
You may play every horror game out there without
being frightened, then play Silent Hill 2
and feel something unlike anything you've
experienced.
On the surface, Silent Hill 2 feels like Resident
Evil in many ways, but fundamentally, the
game makes you work hard to see its ending.
Rather than granting players the freedom to
wander around and do whatever they please,
Silent Hill 2 is crafted to deliver a genre-defining
horror experience.
Alien: Isolation
The original Alien movies are acknowledged
as classics — and rightfully so.
But its status as a beloved movie franchise
means that developer Creative Assembly had
their work cut out for them when Sega commissioned
the studio to create a new Alien video game.
Isolation takes place 15 years after the events
of the first Alien film, centering on Ellen
Ripley's daughter, Amanda Ripley, as she investigates
her mother's disappearance.
Unlike most survival horror games, which are
meant to frighten you as much as possible
with suspense and jump scares, Alien: Isolation
focuses heavily on stealth, amplifying the
suspense factor organically.
You don't want the alien to find you.
At all.
If you really want to have the ultimate horror
experience, play Isolation with a virtual
reality device.
Compounded with the stealth gameplay, it just
might be a heart-stopping experience.
F.E.A.R.
Most survival horror games take place in a
secluded environment in which the player is
alone in an abandoned area or building.
F.E.A.R.
is a little bit different.
The developers at Monolith Productions successfully
managed to combine the best elements of Japanese
horror genre and first-person shooters, and
they did so while also providing a unique
story.
Throughout the series, players take control
of numerous protagonists, set across different
time periods.
But the villain is always the supernatural
being Alma Wade, first depicted as an eight-year-old
girl, and later an adult woman.
In the first game, it's unclear if Alma is,
in fact, real, at all — or if she is able
to manifest herself into the consciousness
of her victims...like some sort of adorable
Freddy Krueger.
The game has a pretty convoluted story arc,
which involves everything from supernatural
phenomena, government conspiracies, and even
a character who closely resembles the girl
from The Ring thrown in for good measure.
In the first installment, players take control
of the Point Man, the leader of the First
Encounter Assault Recon, or F.E.A.R.
team.
Along with members of Delta Force, they're
ordered to eliminate someone named Paxton
Fettel, who is psychically controlling a group
of super-soldiers.
The game's director once said he wanted players
to feel like they're the hero in an action
movie.
That's precisely what playing F.E.A.R.
feels like, albeit augmented with the actual
fear of encountering creepy little Alma.
SOMA
Have you ever seen a movie that wasn't particularly
scary, at least not in the traditional sense
of the word, but was instead disturbing on
a fundamental level?
That's what SOMA's like.
But a video game.
The developers at Frictional Games combined
the best gameplay aspects from their Amnesia
series, which itself might be one of the most
terrifying around, and tweaked them for SOMA.
There's nothing conventional about this game.
There's no combat, jump scares are limited,
and the monsters aren't all that frightening.
The studio's creative director, Thomas Grip,
said that spooking and surprising players
wasn't what the game was supposed to be anyway.
He said,
"The fact of the matter is that SOMA, just
like Amnesia, is very much a horror game.
It's just that it is presented in a different
manner, using slower build-up and more focus
on the psychological aspects."
In that regard, he's right.
SOMA messes with you psychologically, screwing
with your mind, making the most obscure elements
feel eerier than anything else.
Play this one with a friend, just so you can
stay a little more sane.
The Evil Within
In the late 2000s, developers seemed to be
focusing more on action than horror, and Resident
Evil creator Shinji Mikami strived to change
that with his new horror game, The Evil Within.
He told IGN,
"Survival horror as a genre is becoming all
action now.
That is the biggest motivation for me.
…Having the player pick up the controller
and being genuinely able to say, 'Wow, I haven't
played a game this scary in ages!,' that is
what we are after."
When Mikami directs a new survival horror
game, you know it's going to be scary — and
The Evil Within is downright terrifying.
If you're already a fan of the horror genre
then you may be a veteran.
As such, you might not need someone to play
with.
But there's no denying its effectiveness,
and having a buddy on the couch might make
you less likely to pee your pants.
The survival horror elements, combined with
the scarcity of resources, make The Evil Within
even scarier.
It's not the jump scares that get you, it's
realizing that you're out of ammo and have
nowhere to go, with enemies coming at you
from all directions.
Five Nights at Freddy's 4
The first installment in the Five Nights at
Freddy's series was scary in its own way,
while the second and third games were more
on the silly side.
Five Nights at Freddy's 4, however, is undoubtedly
the scariest in the whole series.
Switching from a security office setting to
a child's bedroom instantly heightens the
suspense and fear.
The game triggers memories for people who
were once afraid of the dark, or afraid that
a monster was in their closet or under their
bed...or was the bed.
Imagine all of those terrifying fears come
true — and the only item you can defend
yourself with is a dinky flashlight.
That's Five Nights at Freddy's 4, and it's
absolutely terrifying.
Fatal Frame
The Fatal Frame series is one of the longest-running
horror game franchises.
But the first game, released in 2001, is perhaps
the scariest.
If you're a fan of the Silent Hill series,
you're going to love Fatal Frame, or Project
Zero, as it was titled in Europe.
Fatal Frame takes place in the haunted Himuro
Mansion in Japan, unfolding across multiple
chapters, and it's the player's job to uncover
the mansion's secrets and determine what happened
to its inhabitants.
It's not only about surviving, or about advancing
to the next level.
It's also about the psychological impact the
game will have on you once you're done playing.
That's the beauty of Fatal Frame; it's not
a game that throws unnecessary jump scares
at you, because it doesn't have to.
It's all about the suspense.
If you have trouble sleeping or being home
alone at night after watching a really scary
horror movie, that's exactly the feeling you'll
have if you play Fatal Frame alone.
Consider yourself warned.
Make sure you phone a friend to share the
terror.
Daylight
Writer Jessica Chobot invented a unique story
with a classic setting with Daylight.
Players are tasked with uncovering the secrets
of a hospital by discovering remnants, acquiring
sigils, and bringing them to the Seal of Shadows,
all so they can advance through the game and
eventually escape the forsaken building.
Though the story isn't anything special, what
makes Daylight a truly terrifying game is
rooted deep down in its core — it's survival
horror in the truest sense of the term.
Armed with only glow sticks, flares, and a
cellphone, players avoid shadow people while
searching for a way out.
And when players are confronted, the only
thing they can do is either use a flare or
just run.
Unlike other survival horror games, Daylight's
environment is randomly generated.
Every time you play, it's different from the
last time.
Unfortunately, the developer, Zombie Studios,
shuttered the following year, all but eliminating
any chance for a sequel.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!